-Two nights in a row
we're hanging out.
-I know. You and me, look at us.
-Yeah, look at us.
-Hey, look at us.
-Look at us.
I saw you last night at
the premiere of "Sweeney Todd."
-Yeah.
-And we saw each other
and said hi and waved,
went over.
-Little cuddle, yeah.
-What'd you think?
-Oh, my God.
It was brilliant.
-Yeah, it's a fantastic play.
It was really great.
-Really magical.
-But we were talking
because I was like,
"You're here.
What are you doing here?"
You're like --
You moved here.
-Yeah, yeah, I moved here.
-You're a New Yorker.
-She's a New Yorker now.
-I'm happy you're here.
I'm happy you're a New Yorker.
Are you a -- are you --
Do you people watch?
Do you, uh...?
-Oh, yeah, obsessively.
-That's my favorite part.
-It's my favorite part, right?
-Yeah, everyone's so different.
-Yeah.
-And also, you know,
I feel like there are
so many things that you can
only see in New York.
Like, I don't know.
Have you guys seen this?
Where it's like someone
will be walking around with,
like, a snake around their neck?
-Oh, of course, yeah.
-Right? Yeah. "Oh, that guy."
-Or roller skates or something?
-Oh, yeah, that guy.
We all know that guy.
-Yeah, he walks around
with a snake around --
I know that, dude.
-Snake guy Lemmy -- yeah.
-Yeah. There's always a guy
walking around
with a snake around,
and you go, "What's up, dude?"
-Yeah, yeah.
-That's normal.
-It's totally normal.
-Oh, yeah.
-No, I feel like the beautiful
thing about New York is that,
like, anything goes.
Everything is human,
and everything's valid,
and it's like every day
is, you know, like an adventure
into seeing, you know...
-You said you saw
a guy walking a goat.
-I've seen numerous people
walking goats.
[ Laughter ]
-I've never seen anyone
ever walking a goat.
-You're like the fourth person
to say that to me,
and I'm starting to feel
a little weird about it.
-Do you know
what a goat looks like?
-It's been different goats.
-No. Maybe you're
looking at a dog
and you just don't know
the difference.
[ Laughter ]
You go,
"Look at all these goats!
There's like 30 goats here."
It's a dog park.
-This new breed of micro dog
with hooves.
-It's a dog.
-It's taking over.
-You saw a goat?
-Multiple goats.
Don't!
Don't gaslight me right now.
This is very --
[ Laughter ]
-Were you in the zoo?
-No. This is like --
[ Laughter ]
-Maybe you went
to the zoo by mistake.
-Lower East Side.
-Wow. New York has changed, man.
Wow.
-That's right. Yeah.
-Last time you were on our show,
thank you for performing.
You performed "Boyfriend"
on our show,
and that was a massive,
massive hit.
And so congrats, and thanks
for coming on our show
and doing that.
But I heard that --
[ Cheers and applause ]
No, it's so good.
But I heard a story
that that you almost
didn't release it at all.
-Yeah. So, "Boyfriend"
was something that --
that came out of, like --
I had just done a super small
black-box-theater tour
where I was just sort of meeting
my fans, traveling around,
sort of like figuring out
what it means to perform live.
-Yeah.
-And then we ended.
My voice was shot.
And the very next day,
my label was like,
"You have to start
working on your album."
So we got into
the studio immediately,
and we wrote "Boyfriend"
in like two hours,
and I was like, "This is bad."
And I recorded it
in like 20 minutes,
and we just put it away,
and I didn't really think
anything of it.
And then -- And then, yeah,
it turned out to be, like,
the thing that kind of
gave me a sort of
surprise second career.
-Yeah, well, did you --
how did you release it?
Like, did you put it
on TikTok or something?
-Yeah. So --
So, my label at the time --
-No, I'm serious.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
So, my label at the time said,
"You know, this is --
this is what people do now.
You have to let people know
you're making music.
Would you just do
the due diligence
and, like, put it on TikTok?"
And I was like,
"I'm so bad at TikTok.
Like, you really want me to --"
And so I --
I threw it up for nine seconds
or something
and then went to sleep.
And I woke up the next day
and everybody was like,
"You have to check your phone."
-Shww!
-Yeah.
-I mean, it's a smash, pal.
-Thanks.
-Congratulations.
And now, of course,
I want you to enjoy this moment,
but, of course,
everyone's gonna ask,
"Are you working
on something else?"
Or you're working
on a new album?
-Yeah. So, I'm actually
working on my debut album
pretty much every day now,
which I'm very,
very excited about.
-Closer and closer?
-Yeah. I think
the whole kind of --
The idea is that you're supposed
to write like a hundred,
choose your favorite 60,
get it down to the best 40 --
-What?
-And -- yeah --
-100 songs?
-And those don't have to be
songs that you like.
[ Laughter ]
Which is, like,
actually kind of a task.
Yeah.
-Holy mackerel.
So you're write -- How many
songs have you written so far?
-Oh, I mean,
close to that, definitely.
-Are you kidding me?
-Yeah.
-Oh, my gosh.
-You just write every day.
That's kind of the job
is you just go into the studio
and you just nose to
the grindstone write every day.
-What's the last song you did?
Can you say --
Are you doing with the --
-I'm not gonna tell you
right now.
-Come on!
No one's -- no one's listening.
-I'm only gonna tell them.
You can't know, but we got you.
-Any special guest stars?
-Honestly, there will be --
I think there will be
a few surprise guest stars
on the album.
But my next single
that I'm releasing
is actually going to be a collab
with my good buddy Diplo.
-No way!
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Now we're -- now we're talking.
-Yeah.
-That's fantastic.
-Yeah, I'm really excited.
-Last time you were here,
not only are you a great actor
and singer,
but I had you do voices of
Minions last time you were here.
You do an amazing, spot-on
impression of the Minions.
-Oh, thank you.
-And could you do it again?
[ Laughter ]
-This -- This --
This is why you asked me back.
-Yes.
-Yeah, I know.
-I loved it.
I won't even look at you.
Just do it.
-Okay. I can't look --
I can't look at anybody
while I do it.
-Okay.
-♪ Baa, baa, baa ♪
♪ Po-ta-to naa ♪
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I love when you do that.
Thank you.
Thank you for doing that.
Is there any other impressions
that you could do on my show?
-I can probably do only
the impressions
that sound very akin
to the Minions.
-Yeah. Like what?
Like what?
I feel like --
like, a "Toy Story" alien
is, like,
right in that same lane.
-Yeah.
-Right? It's like --
You're gonna say it's the same
because it's the same.
It's like -- I love this.
Don't look at me.
-It's like...
"He has been chosen."
Wait. What is it?
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
Wait. Yeah.
-Yeah, it is good.
-"The claw!"
-Oh, wow!
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
-That's really good.
-Don't do that!
-No, I was in shock, how great.
-Thanks.
-It sounds like the original.
-Listen.
You're like my publicist.
You're gonna get me
really good work out of this.
-Yeah.
-This is my calling.
Let's talk about "Schmigadoon."
Can we, please?
This is season two.
You play a different character
than you did last season.
What's happening
with this season?
-So, yeah.
So this season,
for "Schmigadoon,"
our two heroines,
played by Keegan-Michael Key
and Cecily Strong,
who are so brilliant.
-They're great.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Yeah.
[ Applause ]
Brilliant.
They have -- They have escaped
the world of Schmigadoon.
They've returned back
to New York City,
and they've realized
that they they feel like
they're missing a little bit
of magic in their life.
And they both kind of,
at the same time, decide,
"What if we try to go back
and we try to get
back into Schmigadoon,
just for, like, a little
kind of like quick pick-me-up?"
-Yeah.
-Yeah. You know.
-Of course.
-Relatable.
And so they go back into
the woods,
dressed in Schmigadoon attire,
to kind of
try to find the magic again.
And they find themselves
in a very different
dimension of musicals
that are much darker,
sort of sexier -- giggling --
you know, absinthe-filled,
and -- and adventure ensues.
-Yeah.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Dove Cameron
in season two of "Schmigadoon."
Take a look at this.
-We are going to become
the best of chums.
I just know it.
And I have the most
spectacular people instincts.
I'm quite literally never wrong.
Madame Frau says that
it's because I'm an old soul.
And she should know.
I mean, she's practically 50,
the old battleaxe.
-50's not that old.
-How long were you two
planning on staying?
-I hope it's terribly long.
-Uh, we -- we are --
No, we -- we are not sure.
-Oh, no!
But you simply
must stay forever.
We're going to have the most
marvelous time together,
the three of us.
In fact,
you must come to see me perform
at the club tonight.
I have a brand-new number, and
it's going to be just fabulous.
And I'll just die
if you don't come.
Promise me you're going to come.
Swear on your lives.
-Just say yes.
-Sure, we'll be there.
-Oh, you are little dears,
the both of you.
Mwah!
Okay.
I will see you tonight.
Au revoir.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow. That's how you do it
right there.
Dove Cameron, everybody!
"Schmigadoon" premieres
April 5th on Apple TV+.
We'll be right back
with more "Tonight Show."
Stick around.